we are diving into the biggest fashion
moments of last night's Met Gala where
Hollywood's biggest stars and fashion
icons were dressed to the nines and
style expert Susie wall joins us once
again live from Vancouver to take us
through the triumphs and misses of the
night and which looks were just so so
the theme this year was Carl Lagerfeld
we know in your first category is in
honor of somebody very important to Carl
Susie
absolutely Chopin his beloved cat who is
said to have been left his 150 million
dollar Fortune so we saw lots of homages
to chopad who was still alive who was uh
on social media last night but did not
attend
um uh the event the red carpet but we
saw pearls we saw her we saw lots of cat
eyes lots of very Carl worthy moments so
we're gonna Dive Right In with for me we
saw him in the tease Jared Leto on the
left shows up as a human-sized chopet
lizzo went to hug him and mouthed to her
team who is this he is starring uh as
Carl in the biopic about the late
designer's life and he's a true creative
and authentic and I think Lagerfeld
would have deeply appreciated it on the
right Janelle Monae so theatrical was
deeply inspired by loggerfeld's Artistry
and his unabashed encouragement of just
being oneself I thought that they looked
amazing and it was this sort of
striptease down the carpet she revealed
later on this sort of crystal encrusted
bikini underneath for me they were both
triumphs because they were creatives
what did you guys think
I agree the net the Met is about being
outrageous as well so I they delivered
on that on that note I'm just looking
for a uh what is going on here paddle do
we have one of those what is happening
oh my God I know try for sure okay
Super Bowl next up we have doji cat and
I think Cara Delevingne Doja this is a
first you guys this blew me away
prosthetic so how show pet is this she
had a prosthetic nose uh the the cat
sort of the the Hood
um the the fully feline floor head to
toe fabulousness on the right here to
Levine a lot of people don't know she
was a dear friend of lagerfelds and
amused at only 30 years old I think it
was really indicative of how many
cross-generational friendships that he
had she opened the Chanel show and I
love that white shirt she was a Triumph
she knew that Carl Lagerfeld owned over
a thousand white shirts so I thought
that was a cool homage most of those
guys absolutely all right next up oh we
got something a little polarizing here
Kim K on the left okay 50 000 pearls you
know sparkling comparisons to a lot of
people online are saying that Playboy
photo shoot that she did many years ago
when she really only wore pearls so
people were saying well great Tim you
were a tribute to yourself instead of
Carl on the right we have the great
Florence Hugh who debuted her shaved
head uh that she shaved a few weeks ago
but saved for this carpet which is a
sign of how cool and what a big deal
this carpet is I love The Feathered
headpiece she's the face of Valentino
for me Kim you get a Miss as a knockoff
of yourself and Florence you're a
Triumph
yeah
okay who do we have next
I think we got some Bombshells happening
with his eyes you know showstoppers
right we saw so many I was I was waiting
for some of the 90s supermodels to show
up we we did see you know Amber Valletta
I think Carolyn Murphy uh the great
Naomi Campbell but let's roll right into
oh Holly Bailey Little Mermaid star
everybody's talking about her I don't
think she can miss a lot of people were
likening that sort of frilly Cape with
the jellyfish tendrils a Little Mermaid
I think she just was Sheer Perfection
Nails the princess look on the right
Amanda Stanford very Studio 54 didn't
you think I mean this was so 70s she's
the face of Lancome I love the Deep
Berry lip super sexy and I thought she
stood out because she looked like an
individual she didn't look like
everybody else and I I give them both a
two thumbs up yes Jeff yeah yeah just
being dramatic yes
okay okay next up we've got Chastain
just the Chastain and blonde literally
the producers and I were like who is
that it took a minute for everybody to
figure it out uh wearing cheer Gucci the
tool the platinum hair she is famous for
not dyeing her hair for a roll or a
carpet this was a wig I loved it and the
great Keke Palmer on the right I see
grape she's great because she's the nope
actor she's on everybody's lips right
now but you know what I just love how
sexy and truly bombshell she looked and
what a lovely person she seems to be so
this is her second met first met as a
new mom yes Triumph to you both good
girls yeah they got to be tribes the
Show Stoppers after all yes so yeah okay
uh Susie musicians known for making
obviously big fashion statements in our
next category we're calling this music
mic drops
Okay so
first shot is of Dua Lipa here do a
showing up looking so elegant she was
one of the co-chairs of the night this
is Claudia schiffer's iconic 1992 Chanel
Bridal Tweed you know 100 carat 10
million dollar Diamond Lagerfeld
discovered Claudia Schiffer when she was
only 18 former juror of course fellow
German National they were dear friends I
was surprised she wasn't there J.Lo on
the right a lot going on here the
fascinator that cut out a lot of
cleavage from the side and from the
front you know no one poses better than
JLo women's 53 years old okay are you
giving so so to JLo
no I'm giving a Triumph to JLo okay I
actually liked the costume change for
Dua Lipa later
I'm with you on that you know what yes
this one was much more good girl you
know homage we get it and again co-chair
so I thought that she Rose to that I was
expecting a little more rock rock and
roll from from Dua on the red carpet
we've got a couple more here and we've
got one serious mic drop coming up okay
cardi B I love how real she is she's
amazing on the carpet this was her first
look like you said here she also had a
second outfit
um the silver wig you know the the
Camellia course that we saw a lot of
Camellias and rosettes last night Lil
Nas acts on the right I mean this is
reading the invitation fully I'll have
you know Jeff in case you're wondering
that's a Dior thong if anybody wants to
run out and buy one of those the eye
mask the
masking yeah right there's a little
nugget of knowledge for you triumphs to
them both for being themselves you know
I mean I just love Carl would have
appreciated the creativity last night it
was really very striking but then we
have to get to the ultimate mic drop at
almost 11 pm Brianna the queen walks the
carpet she showed up with Aesop Rocky
the very Artful read on Bridal and again
she revealed a form sitting down
underneath but for me like you have to
understand the media were packing up
they're picking up their cameras and
their lights they were ready to go the
night was almost over almost 11 p.m
eastern time and Rihanna showed up total
total Triumph for me I love it there's
there are so many triumphs I need like a
holder or a stand for for my Triumph
pattern my hand is getting sore it's
getting worn out
all right we got even more looks from
last night's met after the break don't
go anywhere Susie is not including these
two we're looking at favorite couples
when we come back
okay we are back the party continues
here on TMS and of course at the uh Met
Gala going over last night's looks
rounding up the Triumph misses and the
so-sos and Susie our next category we're
going with the best rest couples
let's roll right into these because
there were many last night beginning
with I think we've got Nicole Kidman and
Keith Urban Nicole of course wearing
that iconic blush gown from 2004 from
that Chanel Number Five commercial we
all remember 33 million dollars for 180
seconds directed by her friend baz who
was there as well on the right Rita
order and her uh husband taika ytt you
know I loved her and probably wrong I
thought the two on the these two were
both sexy smoke shows both these couples
I thought looked amazing check out her
nails look at Rita's Nails amazing on
the left we've got Dwyane Wade Gabriel
Union Priyanka Chopra and of course Nick
Jonas on the right they are walking as
uh first time at the Met as new parents
on the left I was loving the leather
moment from Gabriel and Dwayne I thought
all these couples were just oozing that
kind of crease sheet sex appeal I
thought they looked amazing I think Carl
would have had his fan out I'm giving
them triumphs
we should be using our Triumph uh
paddles as a Carl fans you're right
particularly Rita Rita unbelievable
drippy nails and the manicure Guinness
Book of World Records next up let's look
at some dudes right I think we've got
some men
we do
okay Roger Federer some people say oh
he's boring you know what Jim Courier in
the 90s tennis era was boring this guy's
classic he debuted a new Rolex the 1908
people were talking about he's got a
huge style Legacy on the right the
lovely Tonya winner uh Ben Platt
um I I thought he got a little bit
chopped up by this outfit I would have
left to see him in a higher waist but I
thought you know what it was a little
menswear it was little women's wear a
lot of Jewish pride in there so I
thought he'd made a beautiful statement
Diddy Sean John on the left looking
amazing floral lace puffer what Jeff you
need one of those I love the ornate tape
on the right Pedro Pascal saying a lot
of people said he even out Pedro Pascal
himself this pool boy socks the mini
shorts the red the black the slick back
the mustache I don't know I'm so excited
that the last of us is filming in
Vancouver next year I'm giving him a
Triumph anyways the great Jeremy Pope on
the left 5 000 meters of chiffon silk
bazlerman of course now the Elvis
director but we all remember him from
directing that channel number five
commercial I thought he hit the Carl
look the best out of anybody there other
than his friend Tommy Hilfiger who also
had a great homage I thought all of
these people were a total Triumph I mean
see how that that montage is amazing
this is a phenomenal fashion you guys
you know Carl was about the street and
he was about the runway and there was a
lot of both last night we need to
rethink this guys because when it comes
to the Met anything goes I'm far less
critical as I am on say the honest the
red carpet because I met you know we
award uh outrageousness and class we
love it all I feel less catty today
all right our final category because the
Met Gala happened on the first day of
May Susie our last category inspired
from the movie The Devil Wears Prada and
that iconic line florals florals for
spring groundbreaking
I absolutely love that and yes we saw a
lot of florals uh you know so many
rosettes there's Emily Blunt uh the high
collar the lace that's I mean I loved
all of the details of this she came with
Carl's friend Michael Kors on the right
El Fanning Chanel bride she's wearing
Vivian Westwood she's carrying I love
that Bolero we're going to be talking
about the shrunken jacket on Susie Q's
tomorrow and how that's having a moment
right now the flower crown she met Carl
when she was 13 very cool next we can go
into Suki Waterhouse who attended with
sort of her coming out party with her
boyfriend Robert Pattinson I thought
this was very ethereal and gorgeous this
sort of sheer tool this glass-like
transparency and on the right and
Hathaway with the bombshell the Tweed
Versace again feeling very Claudia
Schiffer to me she described it as
Versace meets Chanel and the split that
never really ended very Valley of the
Dolls so for me all of these fantastic
humans Triumph right again Jeff we need
a placeholder just leave it there
absolutely actually it just tape and
then you know we'll just clear my watch
there we go now I loved it yes there we
go not only that but it's a great arm
workout
you are so right love you Susie you're
always a Triumph we'll see you tomorrow
for Susie Q's